[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if we don't [ __ ] suck this if you're
under 18 go [ __ ] yourself
I don't want no young [ __ ] spinneret
heads em the [ __ ] periscope go on go
fly a [ __ ] kind of some these young
[ __ ] uncle Joey's here for the
adults this is adult viewing
entertainment oh [ __ ] Jesus it's gonna
be a good night [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
this is good I got wheat with no man oh
[ __ ]
then what I do better come back he's
back from Afghanistan
[Music]
we got chocolate and we got no hummus
back to basics and to that score
[ __ ] back to basics remember
it's all about the fundamentals
please [ __ ] blanket he rushes from
the Black Sea of Korea
[Music]
are you [ __ ] nuts or what [ __ ]
July 17th the day the devil was buried
at sea and the only thing that matters
is you you bunch of [ __ ] savages
we'll go [ __ ] nuts tonight I'm sick
and tired of you sick of Doc no fine
oh [ __ ] was starting with the
cooperation in stage boy 1 for the mouse
here we go little David um on Monday
we're taking you deep into the [ __ ]
hemisphere of death tonight
[Music]
already five down 22 to go you know I'm
saying we got everything we got [ __ ] the
reefer
we got Gorilla Biscuits we got
chocolates we got everything y'all think
we need is Julie on the Voodoo Lounge
[ __ ] where you whack [ __ ]
we got the [ __ ] tonight we got said to
sweat we got a gay gret a great guest
and having a good [ __ ] movie
understand had a good day
had a good weekend in st. Louis thank
you if you came to helium the next party
stop is Wednesday night at the Ice House
8:30 $10 working out with uncle Joey
who's better than you [ __ ] and
that's it
the 29th you got the [ __ ] Borgata I
just got Ricky cruise with me to [ __ ]
open up that [ __ ] 9 o'clock then
after the show we watch [ __ ] John
Jones and Daniel Coco Mia [ __ ]
but that's two weeks who gives a [ __ ]
what I'm talking about is tonight
[ __ ] what if you don't like me
get to stab me what have you done lately
nobody knows not even me but enough with
the chitchat and the [ __ ] and it's
time to get down that's why we're here
you came to get down we came to get down
did you're not okay let's clean up this
fight that stuff from scratch Lee stop
till it down over there with the stars
you get more red-faced he bought a bunch
of fake gummies Friday night 38 mm
milligrams
he ate him in like [ __ ] 16 minutes it
takes him two hours to eat five
[Music]
are we doing oh we're doing a pocket
that's right should we do the [ __ ]
the Nazi killer or the [ __ ] perennial
because either way you lose out on this
[ __ ] bargain I'm saying either way
you lose on this [ __ ] box baby thinks
we're running the charity out there
ain't nobody nobody running dick get out
there get out there and mug somebody
before somebody bugs you get upset
that's my model mug somebody before
somebody bugs you like that you set the
[ __ ] president here Eddie Lee this is
the [ __ ] bonnet of love right here
the Stars dunlear 22 minutes eat five
[ __ ] stunts easy [ __ ] steaks and
saran wrap they never enter a room
[Music]
there you go shine on you crazy diamond
[Laughter]
[Music]
in place to smoke the besties I'm saying
look he's still recovering and you think
you can run with Uncle Joe you better
get your [ __ ] together [ __ ] we got
the way to kill [ __ ] Nixon here today
this got to the house I'm [ __ ] sadly
my white foot in the back room it was
fermenting he's missing a [ __ ] lung
he's drooling it's all over and you
wanna [ __ ] come in with mad flavor
you better go to training camp [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
your [ __ ] [ __ ] this Monday
night
you gotta start the week on the right
foot because listen if it sucks in the
beginning it's gonna suck all the way
through so tonight's the night you gotta
be prepared focus you gotta write your
goals and you got a sling dick with no
[ __ ] remorse you understand cuz you
only got one life concept that's what
the church is all about there's a state
of mind it's not a podcast you [ __ ]
Momo's
it's a state of mind you know what that
state of mind is we don't stop well i
sharts till we get the [ __ ] prize and
what's the prize who the [ __ ] knows but
are they hanging out in the corner will
you [ __ ] friends broke that's one
[ __ ] thing what the [ __ ] you ready
for chocolate it's still recovering I'm
telling you guys when this guy shows up
with the reefer it's all over but the
shop you want to run with Joey listen I
feel you but you don't want to do it
stay over there at Starbucks with your
friends smoking joints with filters and
[ __ ] taking you that's the bomb that
killed Lisa at I mean [ __ ] around
tonight you want to [ __ ] around you want
to [ __ ] around you go hang out with some
different people but if you come here to
the church pre it's a whole different
set of rules [ __ ] what do you
want do you want them what do you want
thing why is it there look at me
I got a tattoo of a bird who gives a
Frenchman's [ __ ] you didn't bought more
tattoos of birds to [ __ ] be what
you're supposed to be
the [ __ ] bondage Gilbert he thinks
I'm [ __ ] around I tell him every
Friday leave this [ __ ] I'm showing up
with Monday he's gonna kill the
[ __ ] don't play train on the
weekends couple bong hits never killed
nobody right or wrong you guys know what
I'm talking about you savages looked
just like y'all told Joey you don't say
just let your [ __ ] Uncle Joe where's
the paper towel set I don't be [ __ ]
snortin who gives a [ __ ] anyway I see
the few stars together that type of
[ __ ] night you know how we do it here
you know I got you [ __ ] always
there's no [ __ ] in here we come
straight up with you you want a
straight-up conversation with a
gentleman he's your uncle [ __ ] Joey
in full effect you want to dick around
with these people tell you one thing but
they lit the [ __ ] out of my face
welcome my son welcome to the machine do
you understand me well the pink floyd's
greatest [ __ ] ounce I don't know what
it's called it doesn't matter I'm strong
to the gills that's all that matters
it's Monday night where have you been
it's all right we know where you [ __ ]
fit you see the same that's the mind of
Pink Floyd and you want to come to me
with stories about these [ __ ] new
people
[Music]
it's a beautiful [ __ ] evening podcast
$4.99 podcast 500 Wednesday 5 o'clock
tremendous guests one of the most
interesting [ __ ] people I know who's
doing me a solid by doing this cuz I'm
trying to be the [ __ ] best I can for
you people they can't all be [ __ ]
Academy Award winners what kind of world
would that be you know I'm saying you
got to work for it [ __ ]
but enough with the chitter chatter Joey
I didn't come here for chitter chatter
I came here to smoke the way to death
I'm with you always you remember when
you smoking reefer hydrate place you
don't want no problems
[Music]
I've got a good show tonight that's all
you need to [ __ ] get some popcorn roll
up a few numbers
we'll take lead deep into the murky
waters and that's it and that's that you
know I'm saying I hope you had a good
day
I hope you started the week off today
and [ __ ] beautifully if you will
watch my morning [ __ ] join today you
would have left the house in the right
mindset you would have left the house in
the right [ __ ] mindset but you [ __ ]
around and you miss me on Monday so
funny I'm gonna tell you anyway
let's do another Bonnie what's with the
chili challenge oh you're right [ __ ] you
think you are [ __ ] Johnny Rose
whatever his name is
[Music]
you know I love doing this [ __ ]
podcast I love traveling the [ __ ]
country and then company in two days a
week [ __ ] [ __ ] around kind of
stuff as it means the world you guys
know what are you I got oh gods I got
nothing I have to spunk a pimple on my
nose on the inside I can't pop tickle a
[ __ ] needle in there it's probably an
old coke rock from nineteen [ __ ]
whatever that came to the surface coming
up my tent had a first
I'm doing that white [ __ ] and I can
write a book on the things that have
happened he understand if you think you
heard stories from before my coke they
really have issued this Apple as [ __ ]
ten years ago same November [ __ ]
something out of it but who gives a [ __ ]
as far as tonight we're smoking reefer
[ __ ] in this family
[Music]
you think I'm here playing games you
think I show up here to play games with
you swapping people huh no I thought but
I'm feeling good I'm looking good what
did you do today went to the technique
class kept the lightening on saying you
gotta keep it light tomorrow I go to our
photos to call him Keep Calm keep calm
he's driving he just called over here
interrupted the feed he's on his way
it's a beautiful [ __ ] thing thank you
thank you you [ __ ] see for
everything you do for me
never mind me take it I gotta thank you
[ __ ] guys because you guys are the
good you guys with this the church army
you can't [ __ ] stop us we'll throw in
every [ __ ] day and it's a [ __ ]
group comprised the one thing for the
outer city laughter and love that's it
that's all we're striving for everything
else is background music
for evangelist and Robin
laughter if I knew that you see me look
at me
there's no water there's no thought I
let the intestines suck the TAC out of
the [ __ ] star alright and we still
got a move away so take your time but
hurry up and after the move bar we'll
come back with some light weight I got
the training methods down to that yeah
I'm saying this is methodical I'm like
Louis Biak I'm running a [ __ ]
five-week macro cycle we lifted we
trained with trust me you know say this
is the cycle of death but he don't see
it he doesn't see what I'm [ __ ] doing
I only see him two three days a week
every time I see him I show up with
something all right
the other four days he plays house he
thinks he's [ __ ] Johnny white man
he's yelping he's [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
he's supposed to be [ __ ] he like yeah
this is Johnny white man when he's here
he's alright he's a Jew he gets around
the girlfriend the two white people and
what do you think I think that I can try
cab that he's gonna he's gonna have to
[ __ ] got the straight amount of [ __ ]
you don't say you ready for a bonnet
though the [ __ ] we doing we're doing and
running [ __ ] Rhea the same whole
rehab [ __ ] [ __ ] no can you
imagine we ran a rehab yeah sure I'd be
the best rehab in the world because we
get you off what you came in here for
see has the problem I'm not gonna give
you the problem they give me the easiest
problem in the world marijuana there's
no problem
nobody flunks out nobody fails no no
it's just a transfer religions to i'd
rather than have a transform addiction
from cocaine and pills to marijuana
anything else yeah I'm saying I did the
same thing I just did a transfer of
addiction but you'll see me miss some
work you don't see me missing planes you
don't see me [ __ ] hanging on the
corner I haven't been late for this
[ __ ] thing it's my [ __ ] years
no so that's the [ __ ] to tell and
what am i rehab Council not really I
don't give a [ __ ] whether you
[ __ ] get hired not because
you're getting it it's your world he's
gonna do whatever the [ __ ] you want
that's what makes you you that's why I
love you [ __ ]
but someday you're gonna think of me go
look at that 54 year old he looks like
he's 92 why cuz I'm 85 and
kingi is that's what look at me I got
holes in my [ __ ] faces no I'm telling
you I'm looking for tip-top Magoo 485
anyway youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
that's the place to be I don't want
ain't no [ __ ] stories ten minutes
we're ready to go that's a great guest
tonight it's episode 499 I wouldn't [ __ ]
with you [ __ ] cuz I love you
too much all right I'll see you in 10-15
minutes get your [ __ ] together stay
black
don't forget Wednesday night the ice
house is [ __ ] stay black